okay I catch a boy psychobabble and
we're back at it
son
try to do this
there's nothing else here
94 actually the rooms changed oh okay oh
that's right
payback looking out for one's desires
[Music]
mm-hmm okay this is gonna be a lot of
changing around little clear water
this is very confusing okay
I can't let his gone on this game I go
through here nothing happened
well
this is crazy confusing
it's one glowing
whoa okay no one here is impossible look
Santa Monica hey get back big round eyes
waiting to be fed
[Music]
someone's home uh-huh they're fine
hello sir think of all those better
traditional housewife
all right I don't like that that's a
space the way to go past that anymore no
way to go into the past anymore
eze is dead back then besides New Year's
dead never drink at home
I miss the days when he had jokes and
stars at L okay yeah it's fine I guess I
can't see anything out the window what
else could this bang not great
pictures of mom dad and I have been
roped off
like a hand okay
I guess my MS yes
I don't know what is it supposed to man
disgusting
meet the right person at the right time
yeah they write that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I still [ __ ] that
what's the right time
those are the times so three o'clock and
6:30
I can get that [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
boat
okay say yeah
their way again
that [ __ ]
your [ __ ] now
your [ __ ] now I got your [ __ ] okay
this line nowhere they gone that's on
okay I got ya uh-huh
[ __ ] em how I'm walking is it down I
need a Fitbit on this [ __ ]
so run Jess okay I send this very far
now on the floor ad for private
investigator and okay I'm shading come
home looks like an ad for a PI firm
fascinating it's done here I don't know
it was [ __ ] disgusting it's good [ __ ]
out of me yeah job scare me back down
legging bet I can hear my own dead
chatter through the walls it's too
drunkard
[ __ ] yeah
now this one was 6:30 now wait dad
three clocks none of them we're running
I can turn the hands at this you got
this mixed up
I could've sworn this was like exactly
like this hell yeah brother
all right look at this disgusting are
they fighting that Affairs affairs and
day they won't trip in the front door
it's a good ten seat on the ground let's
like overhand we had such smugly no
smell pattern maquette TV
that [ __ ] always nothing actually
happened
teacher's desk plenty of assignment
papers teacher - plenty of papers
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] tree yeah I take my
sugar okay I come a lot - it's it's a
free country there's a lot I can take
the last yes okay
okay
we can't I anything in here
well what is going on here it says way
to expect any for me huh it's beautiful
out here
okay I get there what this oh sorry I
guess I gotta walk now how loud my style
I'd hell I must have been hello mister
man okay just kidding
can I have yes sir
sir I received a paper plane that was
truly worried you were still having
trouble at home
it looks like my concern was slightly on
a found dead like the white deaf at all
you are innocent main and candid in
nature purchase at upon and snow white
admiring your reflection being different
mothers could be a tough way to live but
I can think I can understand that
failing you said you want to learn more
about my time abroad well I could say
right now is that my past is rather
complicated unfortunately many horrible
things have happened on the sland in the
last decade if they're not our society
wasn't always like this a press have
been called perhaps we should take a
stroll to the boulevard in the weekend
okay there are things are censored
expose don't mention it but I definitely
breath knowing hey Greg yeah great now
just power you know by vice so it's and
I said to him paper plane I read it
how's my worries out and receiver
guidance okay right now
right now
you can't screw the way I'll just toss
it out I'm sorry gonna burp
he's piggy bank you know hello sir this
is a doing anything about picking yeah
Mary kept waiting Terry fat just like me
just like me
okay hey jacked up
and anyway with this part
anything over here is a dead end
and I'd be remiss been like it's been
like a week for you for like five
seconds yeah
nothing really here
oh wait what how's this set
we did all this we did all this already
get out of here get out of here
those handprints [ __ ] disgusting
anything over here again let's say
teacher's desk candy [ __ ] here who say
that's what's doable but I can't
so this all over here it's a colossal
waste of time right right right
yeah that's a better [ __ ] posture
it's all you gonna say there's needles
on the back in here I mean they look
pretty skeptical I don't like how you
can't go fully clockwise nothing else
here
Jewish was like right here yes a can you
go through yet doors locked
the [ __ ] I'm supposed to go it dad hints
but what is this added station every
decision 103 I [ __ ] was that you know
whoa your pinky go where's Peggy okay
right idea no no no sir it's the man
it's the woman
okay I'm current follow that shadow in
the dark anyway closer to the truth
[Music]
see how of a person
okay
kick on
keep going
yeah we go
that's okay no no no no you gotta be
kidding me
no okay Wow you're gonna see what this
is
other studies always neat and tidy him
just give the air seriousness he's that
that were there that your first little
it was always kept even one through the
Fajr erotic great perfect it's just
perfect
[ __ ] is all this [ __ ] mess in here
[ __ ] up there alright come on
that could pay for a pig a
take Tanner
the [ __ ]
and they say there's a pen here and am i
right or am I wrong
that's cuz I'm picky
this is for you
Hank said I gotta say that turns into a
money chair some [ __ ] like that
let's say okay perfect
more of a take it it's almost like it's
going to well yeah how much I find it
chickens are so good for you know you
know like
Oh
okay sure gone this might be ticket
chicken I love Fridays I have a ticket
for you good dad welcome enjoy mmm a
tough [ __ ] it's gonna be [ __ ] up
what's going on here
what is going on here
you gotta be kidding me teacher and
student what the [ __ ]
oh I got the weight sheet your pendant
so that's where I got it from the
teacher holy [ __ ]
why was it
I was it like that
wait
he like hid in the vent [ __ ] is that
so tell me to shut the [ __ ] up on the
floor search warrant
search warrants issue but listen public
officials tried to bribe his camera they
father would've been taken away as my
mom that goes hint dirty but live
hearing this felt like she was smiling
to me perfect clue okay anyway tonight
that guy yeah I was kind of my adulterer
so okay this sorry I can't say what
anyone's minute damn if you want used to
enter the counselor's office the
counseling office is probably that room
in the very beginning you say
locked I don't remember where the hell I
know there's not a locked door at UK
more with how it is said over here
is just a counseling office
No
so I probably never have to go back to
this radio station again there's nothing
here doing nothing there let's say it's
got back la bete con just a little notch
you know it's everything it's all wasted
to seek answers honest
fishies hello airplane and if I could
ask a stick it's all I gotta say
hello sir
teachers that's on our plenty of sound
papers
teachers desks
okay they get that pack in this room
miss [ __ ] what
counter press near its end I'm glad
you're back on track mm-hmm hopefully I
won't be needing me anytime soon mm-hmm
there's anything else you should return
to class now no still plenty of sounds
look at oh man he just talked to a [ __ ]
about me good bouncing markers what'd
they say about me it's over no matter
what's been written on here there's only
fair well okay it's fine
you still [ __ ] sleeping here
okay [ __ ] get out of here
now the door is open three Saybrook
we're not a sign of progress
a [ __ ] loop like oh yeah one let fall
sleep up here and I'll dependent or I
can't find the pendant
hey [ __ ]
[Music]
the best one Tess
you know this class companies in color
are flowing with the center of human
corruption plates in cops clash against
the walls
I thought the bush roared through the
halls the series of curses seething
almost lost his mother's weight bang her
family was once we together how think
Karen when we got it
I'm sleep morning it's all [ __ ] up
it's all [ __ ] up shattered [ __ ] up
you got five dozen chrome line [ __ ] up
ceaseless decay [ __ ] plunging it to
[ __ ] up in floating in [ __ ] up
are you gonna be like that again huh and
dissipating just kind of missin ya
roaming roaming for you I'd like it for
ya large brushing past a pretty flower
yeah yeah jumping around maybe sign
nectar blah blah comforting blah blah
blah
listen I ain't Beauvoir white deer walk
to my gosh what a pleasant surprise
okay this is farewell muchacho stop
meeting keep distant colder air freezing
cold winter pulse get the [ __ ] outta
here
Jamin whoever we need to talk about this
it's yen son I said everything was it
done I can't ever you think you want to
try like that chomp she wants to know
what you wants what now what the [ __ ] is
going on here
how's he you guys stuck you're stuck a
little romance you've given us I don't
know who's been fronting him right now
if it's me or someone else has some
hands okay that's familiar because
everybody's hands somebody's eyes too
but not that much huh yeah I got him
Shadid this yeah that that's he got him
you rejected yeah bromance is that in my
way familiar story he's got now you got
it
with that random guy in the river again
it was like died
I got my teacher [ __ ] session over a
painter of our collection
I saw shatter into pieces then I can't
put myself back together and forget
everything I provide eyes and welcome a
barren Browder full dark
[ __ ] is this a teacher
go home let's go hey what the [ __ ] is
this
and my [ __ ] ghost I wouldn't put the
thing in there and the necklace was like
thrown in there
I can exit I can I get how about my job
job and I should vanish but not our
guilt I am you know yeah you are not me
it's a sin that makes you linger in this
realm and music mirrors reflecting the
truth likeness of yourself
and I won't full of pain and suffering
anguish in what are you further most
well then I stop I may see that we're
all born free hey you gotta walk on your
own path and afraid of losing yourself
yo our bank okay
well what the [ __ ]
so this is gonna be a special level
yeah this could be crazy level
good block my own force
dance on computers down
[ __ ] is going on here
Devon for hope is almost the flight at
diminishing in the wind Kenny that's fun
I guess
[ __ ] is going on here it is like a
secret like learning society some of the
booking contents might conflict there
buddy thoughts
that's material will engage and reflect
me independent pinky let's call it thing
you know what I remind you again
don't tell anyone to never have to
buckle up to anyone else so that would
put yourself when I was in great danger
anyway we like to ask you a favor
yes but it's GM isn't about that air box
already kinda lost him mr. Chang he said
that she haven't come into what happens
anymore put it forget something out
carries from forestry restriction on
imports to in the book club might come
to an end
weddings like this now one more thing
[ __ ] I never brought us any of the
books in the first place right huh and I
can always count on you so they're all
in this
blacklisted to return to home is this
what is this have a sit your next I'll
Bluff is to return home from your book
the fruit or all human rights yeah
okay let's keep going let's keep going
we're off my lemon da crowd may see
what's left of us fine nothing right
come on just do monsters burger take
Sonia mantras the beginning a farm is to
pass your past
how are the road ahead has to crumpled
leave me anywhere and I will follow you
like a shadow okay
I've broken can't get in the [ __ ] is all
this [ __ ]
looks like outside
Wow that is how we do it
okay job capitalists are gonna happy a
man this line goes right through barbed
wire can't open the start cap on that
dark
second word in here
that's [ __ ] you do [ __ ] here
[ __ ] is that they pick on a time like
this [ __ ] in there
there we go yeah we go you do this with
your oh yeah your doubt weirds out
we're an acceptance
we're flying there this one by base this
place is completely lifeless Amen ideas
I heard here you got that sister they
got a Brenda box it's [ __ ] out
remember to throw the really sure if
both had spirit they threw him off okay
give me a tech book page for us to speak
for nine anyway what are you down here
closely with cn how that she had to flee
the country right now he's at true no
she [ __ ] died I think they shot her
or something and I'd like to see him we
don't have any cash - got a safety
aren't you afraid actually of apotheosis
do you know how the writing listicle
eight down time asking question closes
you get hurry and finish this up I think
she was the one that liked it I don't
know what the [ __ ] Abbot well I know is
at home she got [ __ ] up because her
dad was like cheating and should have
been they gonna carry it off Jen over in
a vertical Court Channing gesture
if you can't do since way another's will
uh put the death please guilty sends
fifteen times
yeah I guess it did right now anyway no
I'm Way Fang [ __ ] that
hmm kind of happy I say oh well not
believe that one
[ __ ] is going on here
mmm no no way it may fly through there
okay
just progressing through something just
perusing okay you got that way so we
gotta follow them that's [ __ ] dirty in
here
is there anything no more mom truth game
guess not
it's a [ __ ] broom in there that's a
properly on top of it snitcher where
there Burma hell yeah
who's in it I did that we're entering
the potty where's that snitch that
Golden Snitch
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is going on over here
that time you'd feel free
I love one seat you went to a higher
place you marked leaving me a
descriptive man the [ __ ] that means
I reload the [ __ ] that means
I can't go there
this is getting all [ __ ] up just sit
right here
the [ __ ] is going on here wait
hello
I know on the cart
get see now [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] is happening
to me then once determination this is
the philosophy he polite then that
someone should take fate into their own
hands whether you following him what
ideas do you hold I don't take all their
destiny baby that is a charming table I
was gonna go on if Tammy found yourself
you are may resume okay let's get down
- wake up backwards now
[ __ ] there okay
later levels are a lot less monsters in
very straightforward
so it's locked the [ __ ]
do I have anything [ __ ]
go outside how many times as foreplay as
nothing can be unwound you can never
read em yourself okay and sir I'd like
to report like 20 people this is what
they told the person she was ledger
structure by this typical assignment
[ __ ] before you found our teacher's desk
we got him the country appreciate your
since we got him
it's no good now we're safe you're safe
did you think finding something to rely
on would stave off your affair one day
however here was gone just like that
yeah lost everything you can't depend on
what choice will you make now yeah okay
that's okay she gonna lock that door for
me
they didn't lock the door for me
the roof pages let's look how are you
[ __ ] is this
okay I was a waste of everyone's time
and money
and we're checking they're reflecting
okay
maybe we still want to forget we're
still afraid no Cisco had a bad home
life and had like tuck it out of [ __ ]
teachers or some [ __ ] who was also the
romance person remember the roommates
append it and then they took it on them
and she wagged felt dude
oh they like took out their physical
[ __ ] and see P generations not
confessing the truth I am yeah yeah
you're not me okay yes MA
about Mars water
that person has
- teacher the personal not des yeah
really forget salty but so much
the [ __ ] is this
I guess it's time for this person to end
the show you know waiting at the middle
of on or something for like rewarding
country I'm gonna let to [ __ ] this of
course yeah Thank You Sharon
damn it dad ya know how that's guys
second set I can target [ __ ] JIT what's
that [ __ ]
a lot of foreshadow of this game well
actually I really like the buoys scenery
which is just a day for damn cool but
some things I don't get like why the the
pendant was a hidden in like the docked
and I don't know what was up with that
first kid I like found her as he did she
actually [ __ ] crazy though there's a
lot more to it tonight
really cool game I really recommend it
on Steam and I think my new Siri came
out but that's really different I really
watch how dark it was it's a good one
hey thanks for watching y'all and see
you on the next one peace